let's jump back into using git what
makes a git repository a repository last
lesson you interacted with an existing
repository the asteroids repository for
the most part it just looks like a
normal directory on your machine the
only real difference is that git
repositories store a bunch of metadata
about the history of the repository
since it was created we won't go into
the details of how exactly this metadata
is stored but where is less complicated
it's right here in the main directory
but it's tucked away in a hidden
directory meaning that it doesn't show
up in most file explorers by default
hidden files and directories are often
used for data that the user doesn't need
to directly interact with these
directories and files are only different
from normal ones in that they start with
a period which tells the operating
system to hide it from the users one way
to see these files is by going to the
command line and using LS a in addition
to all the normal files that you see
when you type LS when you do LS - a you
also see the hidden files see here we
have done git so how does this hidden
get directory even get there last time
you cloned an existing repository which
transferred all that metadata over to
your computer if you want to start from
scratch you'll need to explicitly tell
git that you want to make a new
repository in the next video Caroline
will show you how that works